Найпотужніший на Землі термоядерний реактор вартістю в один мільярд євро
здатний утримувати плазму температурою 100 мільйонів градусів.
Це у 5 разів гарячіше, ніж в ядрі Сонця.
Установка розташована у місті Ґрайфсвальлд на північному сході Німеччини
в Інституті фізики плазми Товариства імені Макса Планка.
Експерименти на стелараторі Wendelstein7X
можуть відкрити для людства нове невичерпне джерело чистої енергії,
яке замінить небезпечні атомні електростанції -
стверджує український фізик Микола Марущенко.
Реакція протікає досить повільно,
без вибуховості. Енергія, яка здобувається в цій реакції,
може бути утилізована в тепло і  потім
трансформована в електричну енергію як у звичайній тепловій електростанції.
У відділі теорії стелараторів працює троє українців.
Усі вони випускники харківського фізико-технічного факультету університету імені Каразіна.
Українські фізики створили комп'ютерну програму, на якій моделюють експерименти,
які потім інші команди фізиків втілюють на практиці на реакторі.
Однокурсник Миколи Марущенка - Юрій Туркін, з яким закінчив рАзом факультет
у 1980 році, спрощено пояснює, що робить українська програма.
Завдання в термоядерному реакторі - запалити плазму,
а потім додавати паливо - дейтерій та тритій
для того, щоб реакція підтримувалася.
Можна провести пряму аналогію. У вас є пічка - ви туди поклали дрова.
Спочатку їх треба запалити, а потім ви просто підкидаєте дрова,
а воно все горить самостійно.
За словами Юрія Туркіна, стеларатори будували в Україні
ще в радянські часи, починаючи з 60-х років.
Це тодішня найпотужніша установка "Ураган-3м", побудована у Харкові.
Харківська теоретична школа ядерної фізики і фізики плазми
досі є сильною.
Третій українець у проекті Wendelstein Олексій Міщенко вважає,
що в Україні для збереження фундаментальної науки
слід спершу переосмислити її задачі.
Відсутність орієнтиру,
незрозуміло куди і навіщо.
Відсутність чіткої програми, яку би сприймали,
відсутність мети.
Оце все перейшло у спадок від Радянського Союзу -
великий і потужний комплекс був.
І куди все це тепер має рухатися -
не до кінця зрозуміло.
Розвиток української науки Олексій вбачає лише
у повній інтеґрації українських розробок і наукових шкіл
в європейську систему. Зокрема, виходом для царини фізики плазми
є долучення України до консорціуму "Єврофьюжн",
який об'єднує дослідницькі інститути.
Також відкриває можливості для українських науковців
програма ЄС - "Горизонт-2020" з бюджетом 80 мільярдів євро.
Поштовхом розвитку могло б стати і повернення в Україну науковців,
що мають досвід роботи в лабраторіях Європи.
Микола Марущенко вже 17 років живе і працює в Німеччині,
однак він відмовився від німецького паспорту.
Коли я почав працювати тут,
я мав мрію, що, виходячи на пенсію,
я поїду додому, в Україну,
і я мав мрію, що до того часу Україна вже перетвориться на дійсно європейську державу,
тому що я вірю в те, що вона має цей потенціал.
Микола Марущенко - один з членів команди із чотирьохсот науковців з усього світу,
які наближають людство до нової ери в енергетиці.
Він доєднався до проекту Wendelstein7Х ще у 1993 році.
Тоді новий термоядерний реактор був лише у задумі.
Потім 10 років креслень і розрахунків.
Потім 10 років будівництва.
Цими днями, поки реактор зупинено для модернізації,
на диво науки приходять подивитися студенти, які через кілька десятиліть
й самі працюватимуть на надпотужних стелараторах
і робитимуть нові відкриття.
Микола Марущенко переконаний, що серед них
обов'язково будуть й українські дослідники.